everyone watch up with Collider and I am
here with everyone behind Judy and punch
before we get started I just want to
give a huge thank you to Kia can you
tell your eye they're our sponsor it's
the only reason we get to be here
Sundance is what we call expensive and I
just want to give that Kia a huge thank
you for being an awesome sponsor now
let's jump into I get to talk to you
guys you guys premiered last night what
the hell was that like premiering a
movie at Sundance exciting and
terrifying and great you know because
it's such a bizarre tone of comedy and
tragedy and so to see them laughing and
gasping and all everything in between
was really exciting yeah none of us had
seen the film outside of small you know
theater it's with a few people so to see
it with hundreds of people in a full
theater was pretty yeah pretty exciting
you basically live at Sundance every
year track record of Sundance do you
have a secret apartment on Main Street
where you just come in they're like oh
she's back there's actually a tunnel
just sound dance to Australia no I know
yeah it's really fun I think it's my
fourth year and it's been great every
year it's different and yeah a lot of
fun here well I was going to say that it
is a it what's been like for you the
last year's though and I don't mean to
pinpoint but like you've you've been in
some very interesting and cool and
unique projects and I'm just curious
what the journeys been like yeah it's
been great um I always want to do
something different and I've been so
lucky to be able to have all these
different experiences and yeah I mean
we've such a weird life in movies and
you know you never know what you're
gonna do next and but it's it's always
really fun and different and exciting so
it's been great
most people watching this interview will
not have seen the film yet so how have
you been describing it to like friends
and family
I struggle describing it should really
be working on my page I don't have one
but I think I think that maybe is a good
thing I think the movies really peculiar
it's weird it's absurd it's totally kind
of an
so it's I guess like how go-to is like
sprawling dark fairy tale fable 17th
century fable about puppeteers but that
doesn't give you much does it's a pretty
good start
yeah yeah but I think for me I love
stuff like this where it is not what you
see before where it's a unique tone it's
a unique film and it stands out talk a
little bit about the genesis of the
project and what brought you how this
all come about yeah well I'm glad you
say that because I basically we set out
to do that to make something that felt
you know entirely unique and not like
anything else but it came about I had a
I knew some of the guys at advice Eddie
Eddie and daddy goodbye through my short
short films that I'd made and they they
called me in one day and said are you
interested in we've got this idea to
kind of make a live-action Punch and
Judy film and are you interested to kind
of have it have a crack at that and and
it was very sort of loose and they
encouraged me to kind of take take the
genesis of that idea and sort of go nuts
with it and so that that was how it all
began and then it kind of you know from
there it was a few years of development
and you know a few bad drafts until we
got somewhere well I'm curious in the
writing process how much in the writing
process are you thinking about the
rating and what you'll be able to
accomplish with the budget you have and
how much is it sort of like I'm putting
the best idea down on the paper and then
let's figure out how the f we're gonna
put this we're gonna make this well yeah
it's interesting you say that because I
wasn't sure if they want to made a
direct oh no no no I actually thought
that chances are they they don't they're
asking me to write it and someone else
is directed and Danny and Eddie really
encouraged me to go wild and and we're
in the beginning we're talking about you
know as sort of a smaller maybe two
million or film or whatever um and I
kind of kept calling them and saying
guys ideas in here there's some kind of
big spaces and stuff I just go for it go
for it I'm like okay someone else's
problem just went for it thinking that
um someone else would have to deal with
have it having to figure out how to
actually make it but turned out I had to
deal with that for the two of you talk a
little bit about when you get sent a
script like this how much are you being
told about what this
about and and how much is it sort of
like your agent or manager saying just
read this well I I guess we might have
had slightly different experiences with
this I mean for me it was Mira and I
have known each other for many years and
I knew Mira had written this and that
was gonna be made and it's I kind of
knew the rough premise and I I guess I
was secretly hoping there might be
something in there that I could audition
for and yeah one day but I think I don't
know if you sent it to me or I don't
know how I got it but anyway I I read
the script and was blown away genuinely
one of the best scripts I've ever read
it's just a complete page-turner which
is a rare and and then found out the
Mira wanted me to audition for punch
which I absolutely assumed was because
it's not uncommon sometimes to audition
for a bigger role in order to carve
smaller roles and I just absolutely
assumed out which he's gonna get a bunch
of people to audition for punch
obviously that's gonna go to someone
famous and and then you know maybe I'll
have a shot at one of the other roles
and yeah so when I when when were
actually gobby decided she wanted me to
play that role I was yeah that was one
of the definitely the highlights of my
career for sure I think this group came
to me through a mutual friend of ours
and all I knew about it the start was
that it was a Punch and Judy what kind
of origin tale or something like that
and yeah I just thought it was brilliant
and so funny and unique and yeah I had a
really unusual tone of being incredibly
funny and really tragic at the same time
and I thought if we could pull that off
it it'd be brilliant before filming
begins you're obviously looking at the
script in what you have to accomplish
for each of you what was the thing that
you either were most excited to film or
scared shitless I think we're all a bit
scared of the baby we had a lot of
scenes with the baby and that was about
everything to be honest it was really
challenging it was like there wasn't a
day in our schedule that felt like okay
cool were couple people in a room and
this is you know everything felt hard
and it was partly because it was my
first movie and I was learning and but I
don't know what it felt like for you
guys but you know like a really
shoot swimming babies and dogs and
puppets and theaters and yeah it was it
wasn't you didn't like make it easy for
yourself in any way it was it was
exciting and yeah it all went really
well tough shoot I mean everyone had to
work hard the weather was crap I'd like
what staff shoot but I kind of had this
theory that the I'm the fun shoots tend
to tend to turn out well in the end and
the ones where you like something about
the suffering something I guess for me
it was just the weight of the
responsibility I mean you know
continuing on from the surprise I had
from even getting to do this role I then
was yes just to have it had the daily
weight of do not stuff this up to not
you know this is such an incredible role
in such an amazing film and yeah just
just using the the fear to had to keep
you on your toes basically I'm very
curious I believe you play someone who
drinks in the film I do right so what is
the secret to playing a good drunk get
drunk obviously I'm sure people some
people know this but there are some
actors who really do drink to make it as
authentic for them and then there's
others that are just acting and they're
you know they're drinking whatever I did
that once you know as an actor in a film
I did that once for one small saying I
want to never do it again I was mistaken
everybody yeah I think it's look I don't
know yet drunk acting is one of those
tricky things that you could get it so
horribly wrong but yeah I have
definitely been drunk enough in my life
to have some recall of what that feels
it looks like so yeah because you ever
have you had to be drunk on camera I I
think so but I'm I don't think I've had
any super drunk scenes but no I haven't
I haven't never it's really hot it's
something about like you you got to do
something with your internal balance
right like your eyes have to stand one
place be your body it's just like yeah
right yes that constantly like slight
slight swaying yeah like you're a [ __ ]
you know a tree in the breeze my
question is have you ever do you look at
other people's performances or is it one
of these things where you actually drink
film yourself in the mirror doing stuff
and then try to like mimic that do you
know what I mean because it's it's
really I mean it's really challenging
it's a it's a real hard thing to make it
authentically look like you're actually
wasted I think it's one of hottest
things like I think like spinning around
is really good someone was telling me
that one it's like if you just spin
yourself around but it really throws fun
after like 20 takes like Dan Wylie and
chopper
hey legitimately threw up in the yeah
well it's been many years though one of
diamonds very good friends and he can
throw up on come on dry can't
that's nope anything nope I'm out no I'm
always curious about the editing room
because that's the final rewrite I'm
curious what you learned in the Edit and
maybe what early screenings or any you
know friends and family screenings how
that impacted the finished film mmm it
was good it was we had we had a good
amount of time we had 17 weeks which was
very healthy for an Australian sort of
small Australian film and it was tough I
mean it was it was I sort of thought oh
I'll get to the Edit and then the fun
middle start and the first you know the
first I would say two-thirds the Edit
were really really tough just trying to
find the time it was so much about
trying a fun time once we started to
narrow in on how the score would sit it
helped a lot music kind of helped
there's a lot of music in the film and
that that that began to make it all a
lot clearer we did we've done it a
couple of tiny pickups just very very
small which at the time I just
really didn't want to do but I'm
grateful and glad that I did like really
tiny tiny little things that help to
elevate things but I'm yeah you know
we'd would screen and every couple of
weeks my editor and I had very small
kind of groups of people friends and
family other filmmakers are the editors
and and they're always good I guess it's
that thing you just keep working keep
screening until the notes get less and
less or get more you know concise and
then you kind of start to know that you
you're getting there but it was a
process yeah I think a lot of people
don't realize the challenge of putting
together a movie in the editing room
it's I mean it's everything you know
yeah on that note I have a million other
questions but you have to go to your
next interview and I am just going to
say congrats on being part of Sundance
I'm super happy for all of you and thank
you so much for coming in our studio
thank you
you